hey guys Pete here well it's finally
upon us the end of twin peaks' season 3
I'm gonna do a preview today I've been
stuck in a lot of different things over
the last couple of days thinking about
what I would want it to be as a finale
to what has been one of the greatest
things on TV of all time for sure at
least in my lifetime I did make the
video the other night and I got a lot of
feedback from you guys about what you
want to see happen so I'm just gonna
basically talk about what I think is
gonna happen what I would like to see
happen and just celebrate this one more
time before we have to see the end of it
because frankly we might not get
anything else like this for quite some
time so let's look at what we can
probably guess about the finale it's not
easy to preview anything or predict
anything about this show we learned that
it was one of the great things about it
but one thing that came to mind to me
over the last couple of days is that it
is kind of possible that they could tie
up a lot of things and the way they
could do that is through Agent Dale
Cooper not in the sense that he would go
to Twin Peaks and actually solve a lot
of these things but he may already know
about a lot of these things for instance
when he woke up he was totally aware of
dougie and how he got to be where he was
at for the most part from what we can
guess he asked for another Topa through
Mike and he may be able to stay in
contact with Mike on some level so they
could actually push a lot of these
things to a conclusion through the fact
that even though we've been completely
kind of like in the dougie spot of not
knowing what to do with ourselves
agent Cooper may already kind of have an
idea so yesterday I did a poll on
Twitter asking you guys what you thought
about the fact of Sarah Palmer showing
up at the Twin Peaks Sheriff's
Department of course the last time we
saw her she had just bit someone's neck
out and it seems kind of likely that
she's gonna end up there with those
other players if you think back about
that scene she went out to drink at a
bar which we never had any indication
that she did that sort of thing and the
other interactions we had with her
although we did get
an idea that she might not be herself or
in control of herself she was approached
she bit the guy's neck off and the
bartender or owner of the place was
holding her there until the police
showed up so I think that that's a
pretty safe guess that she'll end up
there now who else is there well it's a
pretty interesting bunch of characters
that are locked up there at this moment
we have Nadeau who we know came from
Jackrabbits palace we have a drunk who
may be Billy but may not be at all he's
actually bleeding or something's pouring
out of his head which looks pretty beat
up and no one seems to be paying much
attention to that the only one that
really pays attention to him has been
Chad because chad is annoyed by the fact
that he keeps parroting everybody else's
words we also have Chad obviously there
and he is kind of interesting if you
think about the big picture of things
you know if you think about the original
run everyone involved with the Twin
Peaks Sheriff's Department was pretty
good on the level type people of course
they were quirky but they they didn't
seem to have a bad bone in their bodies
Chad was kind of out of place in the new
one then in season 3 because of that
fact he was definitely shady he was
abrasive and every scene that he was in
they went out of his way to make you
dislike him he also had ties to Richard
Horne and through that ties with red so
his being there is definitely an
interesting development then we also
have James who's always been cool before
he ended up there he was in he was in
the basement of the Great Northern where
he heard that sound that we've heard
before and he was standing outside a
door
we never saw what happened if he went in
or not and I was thinking about this as
well like he may have gone in there and
doesn't he might not remember what
actually happened we've seen that come
up in some other situations now
especially when the other people from
the sheriff's station went to the area
next to Jackrabbits palace
so James might have a secret or he might
not it might just be there because he
had to get Freddie there who definitely
has a secret he has the green glove that
he got directly from the fireman that
gives him superhuman strength in his
right hand and so if we bring Sarah
Palmer into that mix there's a pretty
interesting group of characters there
I'm not sure if this will be ground zero
but I'm thinking that something
important is gonna happen there NATO is
definitely a big mystery a lot of people
have settled on this idea that she's
actually the original Diane I'm not a
hundred percent sold on this I don't
think that that's impossible to be the
case it's just weird I mean I mean
that's kind of dumb I guess to say
something's weird in relationship to
Twin Peaks but there would have to be
some more explaining done to make that
make a good amount of sense I mean
obviously the theory is evil coop went
to Diane the original Diane took her to
the convenience store and she ended up
stuck somewhere while a Tulpa he created
ran around in the world all of that
sounds fine to me it's just a the
character of NATO and the fact that she
showed up whenever Cooper went through
the mob zone seems a little bit of a
stretch if you haven't gone back and
watched that I did make a breakdown of
the mob zone to look at kind of all this
stuff you can go back and watch that in
preparation that's the part that kind of
throws off the idea of her being Diane
to me other than the fact that it's a
changed actress obviously they wouldn't
make laura dern both because that would
ruin the surprise but one way or the
other I think we will have a better
understanding of what her purpose is
because Andy said that she was going to
be important the timeline is pretty much
impossible a lot of people I put a lot
of time into trying to figure it out I
made a video about that too that turns
out was not exactly right on a lot of
the points but it gives a good idea of
how things are probably mixed up on
purpose so that it's harder for us to
figure out where's what and all that so
I'm guessing that we are actually going
to see agent Dale Cooper arrived in Twin
Peaks on October 2nd I don't have
anything to back that up except for the
fact that that's where it seems like the
store is headed and because we know that
evil coupe was texting Diane that he's
probably headed to the same place at the
same time so will it be just a big
showdown between good versus evil and I
mean that
kind of way or will it be something much
more mysterious as far as the ending
goes well if you think about season two
it had a lot of problems but I've always
said and I'm in my opinion that the
finale of season two was one of the best
episodes of Twin Peaks ever it's one of
my favorites it's hard to pick one as
your favorite because they're so
different the different good episodes
but I think one way or the other the
finale of season 3 will end up in that
same kind of other level of episodes
will it end in a big giant cliffhanger
like season 2 did I'm not really sure I
mean when this season started I figured
it was going to be a one-off event we
knew that the book the final dossier was
already written and it was gonna come
out afterwards and to me this seemed
like it would be at least as far as the
stories concerned with the main
characters there would be a fitting end
I don't expect it to be a happy ending
that ties everything up and we can all
say wow now it all makes sense but I
just thought that and this is my opinion
this was my idea from thinking about
things before it came out that it will
end and one way or the other I could be
totally wrong and in some ways I hope I
am but nothing that's really went down
in the season so far except for some
talk about season 4 happening has really
you know changed that idea like I figure
they set out to tell a story that had a
beginning and an end and now the
Cooper's awake we're sort of in
hyperdrive about getting that
predetermined destination as far as big
surprises go I think that we will see
some more characters I've been reading a
lot of the stuff people have been
posting and I think that it's pretty
likely that we'll get some Leland Palmer
more than ever that I have in the entire
season I feel like that if he's had it
if agent Cooper's headed to the major
brig spot outside of listening post
alpha Jackrabbits palace then we're
probably going to see him reenter the
White Lodge like a lot of people have
always thought that that scene at the
beginning was actually from the end I
feel like that's more believable now or
there's at least more evidence for it
now so I think we will see the fireman
or the giant one more time will you
actually say anything I don't
no because he didn't really say anything
to and II just showed him pictures so it
would be cool if we had that early on
when he gets to Twin Peaks and then that
we see how that all plays out but yeah I
do think there's some Leyland one of my
big questions whenever I asked you guys
about the questions that I want to see
answered and I feel like it probably
will get answered but it's still up on
the top of my list is why is Laura the
one you know the whole episode 8 thing
and the whole idea of the log lady who
seems to be one of the most reliable
people when it comes to things that are
gonna happen and be important really
that's that's one of my big mysteries
like is why is she the one and are we
going to see that unfold in these last
two hours of Twin Peaks I think there's
a pretty good chance of that that's also
kind of tied into why I think we might
see Leland again and then the other
reason for Leland is just because rate
wise is such a good actor like I can't
see them not if they have active
crossovers between our world and the Red
Room I don't see why they wouldn't use
him some more since we know that he is
stationed inside the Red Room and for
all intents and purposes the other big
question that I have and a lot of you
guys had the same one is what was up
with the moth girl thing the moth frog
that came out I mean we saw this entity
that's known as the experiment or the
mother send out Bob but we also saw all
these different eggs and we saw one of
them hatch and the moth rod went into a
young girl in New Mexico back in 1956 I
would like to understand what that is
because that does lead potential for a
lot of things going forward if that's
not the only mouth frog and this moth
frog had played a part and everything
that we're seeing going down right now
then there's still work to be done out
there if you know what I mean a lot of
people chose the question of how's Amy
as what they wanted to find out it was I
think the most popular ones were what's
up with Audrey how's Annie what did
Laura tell agent Cooper and who is Judy
now those are all good questions I think
the Judy question for me I didn't put
that on my list because I was thinking
that we're either gonna find out who
Judy is or we're not supposed to know
the other popular
here is that judy is actually NATO and
for that you know we're just gonna have
to wait and see I can't say that there's
any great evidence one way or the other
because I'm interested in the Mafia and
that whole thing I'm really wondering if
the experiment is somehow inside of
Sarah Palmer or to a lesser extent if
she could have been the girl who had the
moth rug crawl inside her a lot of
people want to know what's going on with
Sarah and I think we're gonna find that
out because like I said I think she's
gonna end up in the twin peaks'
Sheriff's Department and all of our
major players are headed there as far as
Audrey I I guess it would be very
unsatisfying if we didn't find out where
she's at
I didn't put this on my list because I
figured that we would but yeah it's a
total mystery there have been good
theories there have been not-so-good
theories there have been things that
make a little bit of sense but nothing
that just says oh yeah that's what's
going on with her so it definitely would
be unsatisfying to not understand that
by the end I think the red stuff is
pretty crazy that we don't I mean we he
was introduced to us as a pretty
diabolical kind of character and we've
seen a lot of like stuff on the outside
relating to him and possibly his drugs
especially the Stephen and Becky
storyline the kid puking in the car and
he was with Shelley but I'm curious I
mean I don't know if that would be
something that we find out about or not
I mean there's definitely a chance that
once chad was caught the day that the
Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department was
getting ready to move on him and other
people related to this but how would
that fit into the final two hours it's
really so much it's too much man and I'm
so excited but so disappointed at the
same time I could literally just talk
about this for an hour but I don't think
that's the best idea it's this rabbit
hole after rabbit hole with all this
stuff
evil Cooper is going to have to come to
the forefront here against everybody I
mean the Blue Rose task force this is
exactly the kind of thing that they're
there for I guess you could say
obviously with Mike and what he said
about one of them having to die when he
was talking to Dougie coop seems
important and we have coup pieces
putting together a new Topa maybe that's
or a replacement maybe that's for trap I
mean there's so much stuff going on it's
really just awesome and I was thinking
too you know I was like there's so much
stuff going on how could they possibly
do it in two hours but after I started
thinking about Cooper and his
involvement in the last two hours I
think it's definitely possible I mean if
you think about like episode 7 or
episode 11 and just how much stuff
happened right after the other like this
could be that kind of situation and one
thing I know for sure that no matter how
it resolves we'll be thinking about this
for a long time and that's all right
with me so I'm gonna cut this off here
you guys know I'll definitely be doing
videos this week then I'm gonna have to
think about how to move forward
I have other shows I do but it's sort of
like you know the this was the big rush
of Game of Thrones and Twin Peaks now
it's just sort of like what do I do with
myself I may set up a patreon like one
of the things that I loved about Twin
Peaks was the you know a lot of you guys
said that you enjoyed this and thanked
me and I have to tell you it's
completely mutual like this made this
such a better experience for me being
able to make these videos for you guys
and talk about it so I may set up a
patreon because Twin Peaks in itself
didn't actually make me enough money to
survive I mean this is my job and that's
why I had to change my focus to Game of
Thrones because that's the only way I'd
be able to survive so because I'm in a
situation of where I want to know what
to choose for future projects other
outside of the other stuff I already do
I'm thinking a patreon might be a good
idea because that way I can get people
involved get some voting and then have a
little bit of security that if some of
these shows that are really great to
watch and break down don't have the big
viewer numbers then I can still not
worry about not being able to pay my
rent and whatever so I'll let you know
more about that but yeah there like I
said the feeling's mutual man and thanks
so much for watching my videos and all
the comments and everything else we'll
watch this finale and we'll get through
it and then we'll figure out what to do
next
I can't wait but at the same time I wish
it would just last forever so please
like this video if you enjoyed it
definitely subscribe if you haven't
already turn on those notifications
me on Twitter let me know in the
comments if you would be into a patreon
idea it's one of those things it's
really hard because it's just awkward
and the thing about it is is that
whenever you start one out that nobody
really gives money until there's already
other people doing it so it's kind of a
pain in the ass it's at the same time
but that's not your problem that's mine
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon